and then literally my now just right
mandy
break right and i i slammed my throttle
fully forward really quickly i just
rolled to 120 degrees
i pulled really really hard towards the
ground he immediately
started pumping out flares and they act
as a decoy to
the surface-to-air missile that had just
launched and it locked onto my engines
um well i grew up really listening to
stories of my grandpa he was a second
world war fighter pilot and he drip fed
us these fantastic stories over the
years you know
of landing in south africa dodging these
huge ant hills
and i thought sounds like quite a cool
job but there was still one big hurdle
women weren't allowed to be pilots on
the front line you were allowed to join
as
pilots but not operational and um
in combat were you frustrated by this at
this point frustration wouldn't even hit
the mark actually
bizarre feeling isn't it you are there
you're flying with these guys
they can all go off and become you know
fighter pilots
and just because of your gender you
couldn't i was at university so
i wouldn't let the frustration get on
top of me let's just say i played a lot
of sports played netball for the uni
carried on flying loads um and it was in
my second year of university when the
rules changed and literally i remember
our boss coming into the bar one evening
and myself and there were three of the
girls there
and he said girls i have got the best
news for you
and he told us that the air force had
opened its doors to women
uh to fly fast jets and that was it i
couldn't get my papers in quick enough
so what was it like being the only woman
in your squadron i walked into the crew
room and
all the screen savers in what's called
the junta crew room which is the junior
officers crew room
there's like four old you know
old-fashioned computers and they've all
got naked women on them so i changed
them all to naked men
uh and then the next day they were all
landscapes uh so
there we go small changes there was no
female toilet there
so i was always just in with the men i'd
walk in and go it's me
they're like oh sorry just turn the
bodies covering up their
you know credentials um but you become
pretty
thick-skinned about it i became really
blokey i
came swore a lot at one point we were on
detachment i looked down and wearing the
same clothes as everyone else
you know all pilots wore deck shoes
chinos and some sort of blue shirt and
maybe a blazer i was like
oh my god i've become a bloke and it was
just the weirdest feeling and i just
thought
actually you don't need to morph into
becoming
a man if you're in a male job or
surrounded by men you can still be a
woman but doing
the role of uh the men at the time you
said there were other forms of sexism
yeah i mean so we've opened the doors to
women fantastic
what clothes are you gonna wear oh male
clothes obviously so
yeah the entirety of my career i wore
male my fronts um you have to wear long
johns
and yep always with a wife and always
digging into your hips
and there were slightly more uh bigger
issues of course when it got to flying
on the fast jets themselves because
um yeah men can have a wiener jet but a
woman can't
have a fast chest oh yeah so basically
you've got this plastic bag
and it has a little for some men a very
little hole at the top
and it has a sponge a very very
dehydrated sponge basically
and all they have to do is place their
willy into the bag
and the sponge fills up and because it's
so dehydrated it just absorbs all the
fluid
and then that can just be stored in your
with the rest of your maps basically now
all the guys have a wee
right before they get into the jet they
just lit round the edge and but you
i've got all this kit on and i would
have to strip
all of my kit off which would take about
10 minutes to do so i can't have a wii
right before getting into the jet so
anyway i'm taxiing out thinking
this could be interesting anyway after
about two hours of being airborne over
iraq
i am not thinking this is interesting
anymore i am starting to get these
stabbing pains
i said to my guy in the backseat i said
i'm gonna have to go for a wee and he
said right man that's fine
they said just just remain calm i've got
a bottle here
but it was quite a big bottle and it was
full of water so i said i'm gonna have
to drink the water
he said right drink the water i'll be
fine so i'd drink the
you know half a liter of water now gone
right got capacity in bottle to have a
wii
so i said i'm gonna have to strip off he
said okay so i said seat pins in
and basically i stripped off all of my
clothes so this is really complicated if
you can imagine
in a very small formula one car you are
stripping off
what's called a life support jacket a
combat survival waistcoat i'm trying to
get my arms out the top of my flying
suit i'm trying to get it down
i've got you know all sorts of stuff and
i've got my long johns on as well
so you can imagine this situation over a
rack
you've got this thing called a radar
homing and warning receiver here
and it gets little spikes it tells you
whenever a surface-to-air missile on the
ground is looking at you and it goes
bing and it says
sa-6 you know surface-to-air missile
number six so bing sa-8
and every time i was about to have a wee
he went essay 6 right 2 o'clock
when you stop talking and he was like
i'm sorry i have to call them mandy i
have to call them
so every threat that came up he called
and every time he called it
i couldn't wait i failed i basically had
to put all my kit back on and now i've
made the situation
ten times worse because i just drank all
the water anyway i held on held on i
landed by the time i landed i had given
myself
a severe urine infection um i fell out
the jet
and i lay on the floor basically at the
bottom and
i my body had shut down i got into a
state of shock
um a huge temperature spike not just
urinary infection and kidney infection
offline for two weeks
no they've tried to they've come up i
mean i did a test wearing a nappy
grown women you just can't be flying
along an airplane and just
wet yourself your body does not let you
do that
it's still a really debilitating issue
so when did you first see action what
was your first wish i had only been on
my squadron for about three months
when we were posted out to iraq um we
were defending the no-fly zone over
southern iraq we got tasked they were
about to basically put
all of their intelligence through fibre
optics and we were going to lose all of
our intelligence that we were gaining
through
you know telephone telephone
conversations and things like that
because it was going underground
so this would destroy our intelligence
entirely so they decided right let's cut
to the chase we're going to take out all
these fiber optics centers
we've been operating up to what's called
the 33rd parallel so
about a third of the way up iraq baghdad
say
halfway up iraq so this is way further
north than we've ever been
and it was a night mission it was going
to be the biggest mission we'd been on
80 aircraft we were sworn to silence no
telephone calls
lock down in comms from our side when we
were doing this mission
firstly it was we took off at like 10
o'clock at night and we
were heading north it was a really
different feeling
i think it's about 80 aircraft and
they're from four different countries
like bahrain they're in saudi all coming
together
and as we're heading up my nav said to
me mans if you've got your night vision
goggles up or down i was like
yeah they're up he went leave them well
obviously i'm like a toddler
if someone said do something i do the
opposite click my goggles down
and basically as i click my goggles down
they obviously highlight any light
that's in the atmosphere
it was like i was looking at bonfire
night you know over the city on
or you know new year's new year's eve
over london let's say
it was it was that we were seeing
surface-to-air missiles going up we're
seeing tracer rounds with triple a the
anti-aircraft artillery
we are flying straight in towards this
but we went in towards the target we
pulled off
and when we landed there was a predator
it was over the top of our um
our target and we
landed we had a really successful
mission um but we came back to debrief
and the
the uav guys contacted and said oh my
god we've got some footage that you've
got to see
we went over to see it and basically
you've got the building
and you've got this guy and he opens the
door
where my weapon was about to go into he
opens the door and he lights a cigarette
and you can see he's got a
hot cup of coffee or something tea and
it's steaming because you can see it on
the on the infrared because it's
really bright white and he's been there
he's having his tea and he smokes his
cigarette and he puts it out on the
floor and he throws the rest of his teal
and he goes back in the door and he
shuts the door and about
six seconds later my weapon goes into
the door
and it was like oh my god
i've just killed someone and then
he appears through the rubble running
he gets into his car which is parked in
this fenced compound he obviously had
his keys on him
he just is obviously in the safety shock
he obviously starts the engine and then
he just drives straight through the
fence
um like it was in front of him you know
and the fence is now all being dragged
behind him
and he's just driving in a straight line
to get obviously away from the target
and i'll be brutally honest i just went
oh thank god he didn't die
thank god because i
when you sign up to do this you're
signing up to be
a pilot because you have a passion
towards flying
and then the reality of going to war
is there it's very stark it's very real
and then there's a reality of killing
people and that is the next
level up now i'm never saying that i
that was a huge issue for me until you
see that starkly
in front of you and that was very very
emotional
is there a distance from your target
which helps mentally
the interesting thing and i think this
is where afghanistan i didn't
actually fight in afghanistan this is
where all my friends that
basically flew out there so it was a
very different one it was a low-level
war they were often coming in
what's called close air support so you
have the troops on the ground you can
see your guys being targeted and engaged
by the enemy and you are coming over at
low level
literally as fast as you can knowing
that you might get shot at as well
because they've probably got you know
rocket launchers and things like that
and then you'll you might not even have
any weapons on board and what you're
going to do is you're going to
do it's called a show of force you're
going to come over really really fast
and then you're going to stick it in the
vertical
and it's basically saying if you don't
back off i'm going to come round and i'm
going to drop a weapon
that was very different because people
could see
the the impact of their
actions immediately in iraq it was quite
a different scenario we could see it
afterwards on our videos we could see it
afterwards with um
footage from all the unmanned aerial
vehicles the uavs like predator
but at the time you are in the zone of
going through a process
and it's literally like you are
directing someone
to the fiction island library that's how
absolutely measured and professional it
is
and i think that's why sometimes when
you look at that
disproportionate level that we've seen
with mental health issues perhaps when
from the people from afghanistan
compared to iraq then it has been
slightly different as well
it goes through the time you felt most
in danger during your time in war
i was leading my first ever mission and
it was my last trip out in theater i was
going home the next day and um to put in
perspective
lost loads of weight had a great suntan
i was thinking about a new dress i was
going to buy
um we've done the whole route four hours
it's about one o'clock in the morning
pitch black
swept up the last target in the border
towards saudi arabia so
in the arterial routes the ones between
like baghdad if you can imagine up here
and al basra
you've got all these like railways roads
motorways it's sort of like you're
coming out of london
and there's loads of surface-to-air
missiles along there but once you get
down here to the saudi arabia border
which is where we were coming back
it's like nothing in four months there'd
been nothing it's like tumbleweed
blowing you know
and so it doesn't matter if you're
flying a fast jet or whatever world
you're in
you still become complacent i'll be
honest swept at the last target
in reconnaissance mode we were just
taking photos at this point
and i was like yeah going home the next
day god i'm looking good yeah
and then literally my now just right
mandy
break right and i i slammed my throttle
fully forward really quickly i just
rolled to 120 degrees
i pulled really really hard towards the
ground he immediately
started pumping out flares which are
basically a decoy
and they burn a really really hot
intensity and they act
as a decoy to the surface-to-air missile
that had just launched and it had
locked onto my engines as we did this
maneuver
literally pulled away the flares left
and and we
literally in my rear view mirrors got
these two mirrors up here i watched this
missile
we saw it go from being locked on it
pulled off on our flares and it exploded
like this
huge white fountain of you know sparks
about two miles from the jet
now we radioed through what happened um
chaos sort of broke out a little bit on
the airwaves because of all the aircraft
that are airborne
once an aggressive act is made towards
any one of those aircraft
the rules of engagement state that you
are entitled to prosecute an attack on a
target
a response option that you're holding
and i learned
more that night than i have on any other
night not just about
you know how to evade a surface to a
missile that's pretty close up yeah
exhaust pipes but more importantly i
learned about really good leadership in
the form of my boss
you know he'd empowered this junior team
pilot to lead and then
when the going got tough uh and you know
it literally hit the fan he didn't just
take over and take control he let me
continue
and i just grew more as a leader than i
have in any night in my entire service
career
and how would your grandfather feel
between you or what you'd achieve in
your career
i think he would be incredibly proud my
mum is very like my grandpa
and she literally brims with pride
all the time whenever she talks about it
and
you know you know the flying i signed up
as a volunteer reservist
and basically for eight years after i
left i flew cadets
it's how i started and it was really
lovely for me to be able to pass on a
love of flying
and be a role model especially for young
women that were wanting to go into this
as a career because as i heard one of
the first female sort of astronauts say
you can't be what you can't see and it's
still a very very male dominated
environment so we need role models out
there
what i call the the big bang little bang
scenario
if the main charge is separated from the
detonator
then should anything go wrong at this
stage the only thing that will go bang
is a small detonator
still enough to take your hand off but
not enough
to completely kill you